the writer.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We are still in the very long lengthy
narration
of the prophet Sam
narrated by Abbas
regarding the story of the rebuilding of
the Kaa.
As we mentioned and as we have read in
this narration
that the ka was already built when and
is arrived there in that sacred valley
of Mecca but it was in ruins because
it's in a valley and over time you know
erosion
but it was originally built by Adam
and the black stone was originally sent
down to Adam.
But as civilizations rise and fall and
as humanity
grapples with its righteousness or lack
thereof,
the ka
was
laid in ruins,
but its foundations were there and just
slightly.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commanded,
listen closely to the words here. Allah
commanded Ibraim
to take his son is
who was just a little infant suckling at
the time and to take his concubine Haj
all the way out into the middle of the
desert in the Arab Peninsula.
There was not a soul for hundreds of
miles in any direction.
And he left them there by Allah's
command
with a
water skin,
right? Imagine a gallon of water or two
gallons of water
and a satchel
with dates in it. That's it. That's all
he left them there with.
Now, who had commanded this? Allah.
If we were to take a stop right here at
this part of the narration
and look at two things.
Number one, when Ibraim took them there
to that sacred valley
and he set them under that Doha, under
that big tree in the valley of Mecca
and he gave them this water skin and he
gave them this satchel of dates and he
turned around to leave. Hajam started to
follow him.
He didn't even get he didn't give him
anything to hunt with. He didn't give
him anything to make a fire with. He
didn't give him anything to ride.
This is deliberate.
And so she followed him and she said,
"Who are you leaving us here to? Are you
going to leave us here alone?" And then
Ibraim was walking away, not turning
around. Why was I not turning around?
Obviously this is very difficult for
him. Imagine praying for a son for eight
decades.
Ibraim was about 86 years old when he
was given is
he prayed for a son
for more than 80 years. And finally,
when he was given that son, he tells him
while he's still an infant, take him out
into the middle of the desert in the
middle of nowhere and leave him there.
This is not easy for Ibraim.
But it's Allah's command.
And Ibraim,
if we were to stop him at that moment
and say, why has Allah commanded this?
Listen to the question. Why has Allah
commanded you to do this?
Did he know?
Most likely he did not know.
He did not know. Or if he did, he did
not know how this was in any way working
towards that ultimate goal of rebuilding
the Kaa. Why doesn't stay with me in
Hashem? When he grows older, we'll come
back together and we'll rebuild the
Cabba. No, take him now.
And then asked him a critical question.
She said,
"Did Allah command you to do this?"
He said, "Yes, Allah commanded me to do
this." She said, "Then in that case,"
that's all she needed to hear. She said,
"In that case, Allah will not lose us."
And she went back dutifully and sat down
under that tree. She has no idea why
they're there. What greater purpose this
serves if we were to stop at that moment
and say, "This is for a great purpose."
Tell me, what great purpose does it
serve for a woman to take her infant
child and sit out in the middle of
nowhere? What great purpose could come
of that?
But but the as the poet says
that if Allah wants to,
he will take the most tattered, beaten
down thing and make it into a gem. If
Allah wants to, if you and I were to go
back in time and be shown the place
where is and were and you were to be
told looking around,
all you see is desert.
As far as the eye can see, you know what
the desert is? Death.
Desert. And death, they are synonyms in
our world here on this earth.
Nobody can survive the desert,
not without years upon years of training
and knowledge.
And so if you and I were to go back
there and stand there with and
look around and see nothing but death
everywhere
and then we were to be told, you see
this place right here, middle of
nowhere, this desert,
this is going to be the most visited
place on earth.
Every single
every single inch of humanity on this
earth, wherever day and night go, people
will come from those stretches to come
to this point right here.
That would be pretty hard to believe,
wouldn't it? But what is Allah's
description?
Yet
he brings forth life from the dead,
doesn't he? He brings forth life from
the dead.
And this is very very very apparent when
Gibl finally comes. Now Hajar is there.
She is suckling her child. She runs out
of water. She runs out of dates.
Night is coming.
sounds. Imagine how frightened she must
have been. She's looking around. She
knows Allah is going to send something
for her, but she doesn't know what it
is. She's looking for it. She's trying
to figure out what is expected of her at
this moment. And I guarantee you all of
us collectively had not been in onetenth
of a difficulty as Haj were was in this
moment.
But she sat there dutifully waiting for
Allah's decree to unfold
and she started getting thirsty and her
son started to squirm from hunger crying
incessantly as a baby.
And so Haj instead of just sitting there
she couldn't take this anymore. So she
went up to the closest mountain which
was a safa and she stood on top of that
mountain to get a higher vantage point.
She's looking around to see where
Allah's relief is going to come from.
And then she comes down from the
mountain and as the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
when she passes is to go up onto
she covers her face with her with her
dress so that she doesn't have to look
at her poor child squirming from hunger
and she goes up onto Marwa and she looks
out and then she comes back down and as
she comes between Marwa what does she do
she jogs lightly ly to get past this
without having to look at him. And she
goes up onto a saf and then back down
and again seven times. What is that?
That is what we do today in
that is why when we arrive between
we jog.
If we were to stop Haj at that moment
and say, do you know what? Billions and
billions and billions of men and women
from all walks of earth, kings and
servants, old and young, are going to
come here and imitate you for the rest
of time. That would be pretty
unbelievable at that moment, wouldn't
it? But who knew that such such steps
that she took, but she took them in
faith. And now Allah makes all of the
rest of humanity
worship him the way that Haj worshiped
him that day.
And so on her seventh time, she gets up
on top of Al Marwa and she hears a sound
and she says, she's the only one there.
She's the only one there. She hears a
sound. She says, "Quiet."
Telling herself, "Quiet."
She hears it again. She turns around and
from the top of Al Marwa, she looks down
and she sees Gibl
standing next to that tree. Is squirming
there next to him. and he looks up at
her and he touches his wing to the
ground and the spring of Zem starts to
come out of the ground.
And so
fast forward
and the travelers of Jorum,
they come by and they see birds circling
over the valley of Mecca. And those
birds only circle over water in that
way. But they have traveled this desert
for generations. And they know for a
fact that there is no water over there.
There is nothing but more emptiness and
desert over there. There's nothing but
more death over there.
And so they send a scout
and they see one of the most bizarre and
excuse the term, one of the most
creepiest sites you could ever see in
the desert. Imagine yourself. You're
traveling through the desert. You know
this place very well. You come upon the
valley of Mecca. You see birds. You look
down. There's water coming out of the
earth in the middle of the desert. And
there's a woman with an infant child
sitting there under a tree. No horse, no
camel, no nothing. How did she get here?
Where did she come from? That's the
sight that you see. It's very bizarre.
And so they asked her to come down and
she said, "You can come down, but the
water is mine."
And so they agreed. And so they came
down and they moved into that valley.
And slowly over time, more and more
families moved up from Yemen and settled
in that valley of Mecca. And Ismael grew
up amongst those original Arabs.
And he learned two main things from
them. He learned archery and he learned
the Arabic language.
And he became
as the prophet describes him.
He became the best of them at those two
things. So the point that it said that
is
that is the first to ever have perfected
the Arabic language and to have written
it in you know written its its
letters and to have digested it
and wrote in the Arabic language. And so
as he grew up, everyone was proud of
Isah. And finally they married their
daughter to him. And now is a young man.
He's an archer. He's one of them. And he
is married to their daughter. And we
will continue this tomorrow inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]